want me to read you what david goggin
sent me on my birthday he's a he's an
awesome human being he's i mean he's not
a lot of those i love you there's not a
lot of those out there this day 54 years
ago
you took your first breath with taking
that first breath it made you eligible
to die
i hope you're not enjoying your day by
sitting on the [ __ ] couch with your
feet up hopefully out there somewhere
suffering talking to that in a [ __ ] see
joe the inner [ __ ] loves [ __ ]
birthdays why
because it makes you an even bigger
[ __ ]
because we feel it's our special [ __ ]
day
so we can just chill the [ __ ] out
most people wake up to just exist on
this planet
so joe
if you haven't gotten the [ __ ] after it
yet maybe you should
five exclamation points i'm obsessed
with him i love you dude happy [ __ ]
birthday
five ex commotion points goggins out six
exclamation points
i love him he i
listened to his book like three four
times
this is the greatest birthday messages
ever really is stay hard